Welcome to another Epic Games Unreal Engine training course.
Today we're going to be taking a look at an introduction to animation
in Unreal Engine version 5.5.
So we're going to aim to end with an understanding of the different types of animations
that you have within the engine.
And we'll take a look at the animation editors and the different features that are available
depending on what type of animation you're working with,
how you can import and export animations to and from the engine.
We'll also get an understanding of the differences between skeletons and skeletal meshes
and cover a brief overview of the animation subeditors.
Then we'll go over how to create some new animation assets within the engine
and for that we'll utilize Sequencer and pre-existing animations
and we'll briefly cover how to attach an item to a character using a socket.
So when we're talking about the different types of animation that you can have in engine
what do we mean by this?
So it's more understanding what you're going to use that animation for
which will sort of dictate how you should approach creating the animation
and how you set the animation up in engine.
The first type of animation you could consider is what we might call input animation.
So these animations are typically used for the player character that you're controlling
and they're authored on the spot so the character won't be moving through space
when you export these animations.
Now the reason for that is that it's not the animations that dictate the character's movement
but something called the player pawn.
Now the player pawn is essentially a container of logic
that takes the input information from your controller or your keyboard or your iPad
or whatever it might be that you're using to control the character
and it dictates what the character should be doing when you press a certain button.
So when I press W on my keyboard the character's moving forwards
and when I press S it's moving backwards.
And you can see this sort of container around our character here
something that's called the capsule.
Now this is just a visual representation of where this character's moving and how they're moving.
So as I traverse around the space you can see that that container is moving
and we've got animations playing within that container.
Now it's the animation blueprint itself that dictates what animation should be playing on the character
and it sort of gives that illusion of movement.
So as this capsule is moving through the world
these animations are playing on the spot
at a speed that matches the capsule's speed
to give that illusion of movement.
And this can be done with all sorts of different animation types
so if you're jumping, you're running or walking, you're flying or swimming
you know whatever it is you want your character to do
you'd first set up the inputs from the controller to the player pawn
and then that information is fed through to the animation blueprint
which tells the character what animation to be playing
and how it should look when it's moving in a specific way.
And the other type of animation we would call linear animation.
So this is more often used for cinematics
or something that doesn't need to be controlled at runtime essentially.
And also this means it doesn't need to be authored on the spot.
So this is where our character or whatever it might be
can be moving through space in the world
and not worry about having to make adjustments at runtime.
So this could come in the form of animations that you've created in external software
or you could actually create them directly in the engine
using Control Rig inside Sequencer
or maybe you've got pre-recorded mocap or alembic caches
that you could also set up inside Sequencer.
But the key point is that they don't need to be controlled at runtime
and it's something that doesn't need to be authored on the spot
the same way that an input animation needs to be.
It's more like a one shot or a cinematic that would trigger once
and then you would just allow that to play out.
Digging a little deeper into how animations are set up in engine
we have something called root motion.
Now earlier I said that it's not the animation
that drives the movement of the character
but it's actually the movement of the character
that defines what animation should be being played.
So whether that's walking or jumping or running, whatever it is.
Now root motion is a way of actually flipping that relationship.
And as you can see here, it's a method to control the character's movement
using the animation data on the skeleton's root bone.
So looking at this GIF that's playing on the right hand side
you can see that as the animation plays
the character is moving forward through space
and as they return to that idle pose
you can see that they blend back to the capsule
because they're currently exiting the capsule with the animation.
Now when you enable a root motion inside the animation
you can see on the left hand side here
that that information on the root is being transferred to the capsule
and as they're blending back to idle they're not snapping back
because the capsule is now moved to where that root would have been.
Now an important thing to note here
is that a skeleton needs a root bone for this to work.
So if you're downloading animations or skeletons from somewhere online
like Mixamo for example
you might find that they don't actually have a root bone
or they're using like the hips or pelvis in place of it
and it's actually in the wrong place.
So what you need is a root bone, a unique bone
that's at the top of the hierarchy
that is at world zero by default.
A second thing to note is that
root motion is not enabled by default.
So this is something that you need to enable in the animation itself
and then something you need to set up in the animation blueprint
to take the data from the skeleton's root bone
and transfer that to the capsule
so that you can get the movement from it
and use that when you're controlling the character.
To give an example of this
you can see that we've got a root bone at the top here
the top of all of our hierarchy
which is essentially your reference point
for the entire skeletal structure
and so everything would be a child of this
in one way or another.
Now in characters like bipeds or quadrupeds
or anything that's living typically
the root goes to sort of a central branching point
that is typically the pelvis or the hips
and then everything else branches off that
in smaller branches like your spine
your hands down to your fingers
or your thigh down to your feet.
And what you'll find is with something like a car
or something mechanical that's non-organic
you may actually have several of these branching points
depending on the requirement of the thing that you're animating
or what the mesh needs to do.
Now organic characters often require things like twist joints as well.
Now these allow you to preserve the volume
of like forearm for example as the wrist twists
and the recommended hierarchy for these
are that they're best created as individual children
of for example the elbow
rather than being in a direct chain
from the elbow to the wrist.
Now this just gives you more control over the rotation
without affecting the other joints in the chain.
And overall the key to the successful skeleton
is just the hierarchy
and considering how your character needs to deform
and setting up the hierarchy and service of that.
So we've looked quite a bit at gameplay animations
and how you should set up your skeleton
and the reasons why you might animate something
on the spot or whatever.
But now if we compare sort of
cinematic animation pipelines
sort of in engine and out of engine
you'll find that a pre-made animation pipeline
you know it's a fairly rigid workflow.
It's been developed over many years
by many different companies.
You know typically you'll create
and you'll animate your characters
in an external software like Maya or Blender
and then you'll bring those baked
animations into the engine
where you would then you know
set up the logic to utilize those
animations. So typically in
Sequencer the cinematic tool in engine
you'd take those baked
animation assets and you could
maybe stitch some animations
back to back blend them with one another
even apply some animations
additively to get like some facial
animation on there or
some other additive animation
on there. But any
animation any edit you need to make
really you tend to come
back into your external software
make that edit export
your animation and then import it back
into the engine.
Now you can
modify the animation in Sequencer
with the FK control rig that
comes with it. So you could bake to the control rig and
then make your edits and then bake that back down to
an animation sequence.
But typically what you would
do is you would go back to your
external software make your edits and bring that
back into the engine. And here's
an example of you know that typical pipeline.
It's quite like an
assembly line where one thing
typically needs to be completed before the next
thing can start. So kicking
off with your story development your story
boards getting those
iterated on and then going
back and forth with the tutorial and
as soon as they get signed off
that then allows you to start your modeling and
your rigging and your you know your
scene set up.
And as soon as that's all worked on and that's set up
and that's been signed off you can then
start animating so you can start blocking
in your rough layout of your
you know your characters animation
and then you'll keep
iterating back and forth back and forth back and
forth until that's signed off. And once
that's when the next the next team
can kind of jump on it and start working on
maybe it's effects or crowds
or moving on to
lighting after that. But you'll see
that typically one
thing can't really start until the
previous has been completed
and comparing that to
the pipeline in engine you have
a lot of tools that will allow you to keep the rigging
and the animation inside the engine
without the need for re exporting
and then re importing when you need to make some
changes. So tools within
the engine like control rig
and I've got access to
procedural rigging and modular rigging
and these allow you to
create templates for different parts of
the skeletons that work instantly
across multiple characters in the project
so you could create and set
up sort of FK and IK arms
and legs that you can instantly just plug
into different characters and that will just work straight
away. You can then animate
directly in the scene that you're rendering
in with your control rig inside the sequencer
so this allows you to
work with other teams in parallel as the scenes
are being built and you're not having to wait
for them to be finished before you can start
before you can start animating.
Some of the newer tools in Unreal
Engine as well actually allow you
to create skeletons
and skin characters directly
in the engine. This is available
from version 5.3 and
above which means that your
entire rigging and animation process can live
inside the engine working with the assets
and the final scene that you're rendering out.
A real-time pipeline has
a few benefits over the offline pipeline
or the pre-made pipeline.
So all the previs
can be done directly within the engine
and then as you're working through each
iteration you update with the final
assets as they're being created.
You don't have to throw away any work
and everything that you're doing is building
towards that final shot through each iteration.
Now that allows teams to
work more in parallel with one another
rather than the waterfall effect
where you're waiting for one to finish before you can
kick off. You can get your characters
rigged and set up
and animated in scenes that are being
set up at the same time
and a huge advantage
is being able to animate within the actual
scene that you're rendering and you can see
all the real-time lighting, how that's affecting
your character, all the
effects that are in there and anything that
your character will be interacting with in the final
shot all happening in real-time.
And all of that together gives you
sort of a faster iteration
time without having to jump between different
softwares, importing and exporting.
You're also not having to wait for renders
to see how your shot looks
because it all runs in real-time
and gives you more sort of opportunities
to experiment and more creative
freedom to try things that would normally
probably be too costly or
time consuming with that traditional linear pipeline.